the emmys are coming up and i'm sure
you're are you nominated i assume you
must you've heard okay but you said i'm
really rooting for conan to win the uh
emmy he's no longer doing his late night
show and you feel this is his last
horizon no you would rather he win the
emmy than you well
listen i don't think
i'm not that nice a guy i mean yeah we
would love to win i mean i just know
we're not going to win the emmy so um i
i think it would be a nice thing i think
i feel like conan's greatness has been
um overlooked over the last like five or
six years i think it is a result of him
being on a cable television channel and
i think that's the only reason i think
if he was still on network tv he would
still be nominated for an emmy every
year and
and i do think that
especially amongst comedians and his
peers he is thought of as one of the
greats
and um i think that would be nice i mean
it i think it's certainly deserved i
mean i know the emmys isn't a lifetime
achievement type situation but
i do think that conan
not only was he did was he
really funny and very consistent which
is hard but i think he he stuck to his
guns you know you were the one who
turned me on to andy richter in a way
because uh you know andy was conan's
long time sidekick but i remember going
to your wedding and i kept walking into
andy richter and his wife all day and
you know because we were all hanging
around waiting for you to get married
and this [ __ ] guy leveled me with his
his comedy was just unbelievable
what a funny guy you will not find two
funnier guys in like real life than uh
than conan and andy i mean those guys
are
really funny guys
yeah in fact i emailed with conan last
night and i was like how's it going you
know uh um
i said does andy still come over and sit
on the couch and he said that he said uh
yes i just threw the commercial break
which is probably what we'll all really
do when we get old and senile